[Music]
um well every Tuesday they are the
loudest bunch at the bowling alley and
they might just be having the most fun
too a bowling league in Westland doesn't
have to bowl the highest score to
impress and Inspire here's CBS 2's no
Brennan
so it's the time right now it's Focus
could not be clearer I need a good
businessm hold on we're doing this again
no it's something it's not what you
think what do you think it is
it's even better
it's even more wild it's here Darren
snobling straight is in this for the
competition you don't have to be the
best bowler but it does help
oh no
yeah
and when you're winning don't say it
let's let everyone figure out at their
own pace okay one wants to be in the
losing Lane I like knocking them pins
down folders in this league at
westlawn's lawn bowl track pins and
attract trouble
for the competition Chicago
troublemakers the Chicago troublemakers
win one cause no trouble but we might
make some
after every role they rely on their ears
ma'am you threw your bowling ball at the
arcade and broke our Ninja Turtles
machine
and it was the turtles in time one I'm
very upset I can't get those anymore how
much those cost to repair they're so
vintage and it was the four man one with
four people could play at the same time
so now we're [__] okay
so thanks a lot and um
you just threw your ball through a
birthday party
you know what I've seen literal like
[Music]
I've seen like actual like teenagers and
young adults go on a date and use the
bumpers for bowling oh yeah how do you
feel now instead of their
why would you do this sport if you can't
see
I'm just saying I think it's fun I think
you know what can I I want to start a
blind shooting league
they already have female shooting leads
police officers
the female police Union
Nevada for years Marsh
eyes down the middle well I lost my
sight back in 1999
there are worse Sports yes sir I
understand but the bowling alleys next
door this is Walmart you broke all our
Samsung TVs
he's like I was a championship bowler
and then I lost my sight in 1999 because
I was looking down in the ball return
for my ball because it was taking too
long and a ball came up pop got me right
in the eye and I said to myself would I
hurt oh and it also wasn't my bowl so
then I stuck my head back in the hole
and a boom wouldn't you know it another
ball my ball came back boom hit me right
in the [__] eye and I ain't been able
to see ever since then I owed my
landlord rent so I teamed up with an
Amish guy and we
joined a bowling league and Bill Murray
had really bad hair
piece of [__] [__] you
oh [__] man this is [__] crazy I love
it see if anyone's eating food there see
if any of our fans were there be so
funny if they sent the media guy there
and he was like me he just assumed oh
we're doing another one of these wow
black people Bowl stories and he just
starts being like so you know wow this
is great so you started a whole league
uh how difficult has it been bowling
being an African-American and they're
like what wow we all blind and he's like
and then they go and then they go then
they go
I'm black
and that [__] report is in there next
week apologizing to the [__] the
producer like look I'm sorry you sent me
to do Blackwater Polo and [__] you
know black fencing and all these black I
thought this was another black is that
when a black guy sells something at the
pawn shop that he stole
yeah black fencing in order to do that
you have to find the Thieves Guild
if I knew I was black I wouldn't be
bowling
[Music]
mental illness mounted compression
situation I went through something where
I tried to take my life
is that how you lost your site
what bowling has done for me is giving
me an opportunity to socialize with some
very great people we'll take that gives
you something else to do other than
sitting around the house Darren Lost His
sight but not his sense of competition
I'm gutter balls but like his buddy next
to him just keeps playing the sound
effect on his phone to make him feel
better
another good one man another strike I
don't know how you do it bro you're so
good I play basketball overseas in Spain
1994 tonight whoa 1995 now I'm sad yeah
from the court to the Lane he still
leans on teammates they went into the
lab like Gail Patterson who's been a
troublemaker since the early 80s well my
first thought was how was that possible
you know the pins are way down there and
they can't see them railings guys thank
you ma'am that's exactly we know what
being blind Miss
Boulders away from the gutters very nice
tell me honestly they're better at
bowling than I am I can see when they
throw that person they're better than
dick Masterson at least their arms
didn't rip off that is also true ball
all right is it coming back all right so
what are we going to do line race car
driving I want something spicier they
[__] already have race car driving in
Japan
all right that was a good ball get
knocked down four off the right
what about blind MMA like once they find
each other they've had blind boxing
before we've seen that okay guys the
game is the same these folks are bowling
like pros you know what's wrong about
having fun and so I mean like like think
about it right if you had blind mixed
martial arts
then it would be like you know pretty
much like 30 seconds of no action
per round while they're trying to find
each other and then there would be some
action it would basically be like
heavyweight UFC every round there's no
action until like the last 30 seconds
and then they wail on each other once
they find each other and then they take
a break
of humility mind slap fighting oh man
don't
having a great why is it every time as a
disabled person you guys want to start
fighting it with them it's like every
time beeping on that they have like
beeping things on their heads bro you
guys used to really like bum fights
didn't you time I love to bomb fights
bro when we step I know pessy you
watched them the other day right yeah a
little while ago merch was on we were
just watching we're like oh oh this is
all illegal yeah I came on specifically
I think he invited me for bum fights
because I came on specifically four bomb
fights but yeah that was because we grew
up uh in high school there was like my
group of friends if you were like if we
had a house party right and like there'd
always be most of the people would be
outside chilling but anyone who is
inside chilling in the living room the
TV always had one of two things on
either bum fights or it had an N64 and
no mercy and people would bring their
[__] memory cards and [__] yeah
that's pretty much my ass bring their
own characters and [__] bro I used to
play I
machine bro I was such a tasmark
[Applause]
as loud as the bowling alley gets
you can hear
every pin drop there are three bowling
leaks for the visually impaired that
compete here at launch who cares about
no they know the [__] [__] anyway
brother yeah even he's doing better than
me you [__] never hear from no
they're just one they're here every
Tuesday two other leagues compete on
Saturdays smug